[Music]
as the weather begins to warm up coyote
sightings are becoming a little bit more
frequent here in the valley the nevada
department of wildlife is asking
residents to be on alert especially if
you've got pets christian gassed us with
the story tonight
she's not just you know a pet she's an
actual family member tracy mackey enjoys
spending time with her new puppy mabel
but a recent trip to this henderson park
reminded her of the dangers that lurk
around the desert it was a nice day just
like this
and all of a sudden we heard some rocks
just kind of tumbling down from the
mountain and i turned over and the
coyote was right there just standing
still
just really scary luckily maggie was
able to scare away the wild animal
coyote sightings according to doug
nielsen from the nevada department of
wildlife become more common as the
warmer weather rolls in if you spot a
coyote he says it's normally not an
emergency but residents should be aware
of what to do we need to do is we need
to haze them we need to let them know
that they're not welcome where we're at
and that they need to move on parks
hiking trails and even urban development
nielsen says are common areas for
coyotes since we live in the desert the
concern is higher when they visit the
backyards go out with your dogs cat and
be there with them don't just put them
outside the other things that we want to
avoid are generally dawn and dusk hours
that's when they're most active nielsen
says residents can be proactive keeping
trash bins closed pick up any pet waste
avoid leaving food outside and always be
alert if you have water since they are
always looking for a break from the heat
just scream and yell common tips mackey
says she lives by to keep her new pooch
safe i would literally grab her i would
do the best i can to save her christian
casa is live local now